[Música]
hola bienvenidos a migrantes el programa
semanal de france 24 sobre el éxodo los
saluda juliet riaño
[Música]
la recepción de solicitantes de asilo en
eeuu ya es un hecho coincidiendo con el
primer mes de bailén en la presidencia a
los migrantes varados en méxico por las
medidas impuestas en la anterior
administración comenzaron a ingresar a
territorio estadounidense donde
esperarán el desarrollo de sus trámites
de refugio se trata de la primera medida
con la que byd en esperar restaurar el
derecho de asilo en eeuu y que podría
beneficiar a unas 25 mil personas la
frontera está abierta para migrantes con
procesos activos pero cerrada para
nuevos casos así fueron los primeros
ingresos
es el final de una larga espera
ellos son el primer grupo de 25
solicitantes de asilo que pertenecían al
programa de protocolo de protección de
migrantes a los que se les permite la
entrada de eeuu establecido por la
administración de donald trump el
llamado mpp también conocido como
quédate en mexico los obligaba a esperar
la tramitación de sus casos del otro
lado de la frontera sur
su llegada representa un nuevo paso de
la administración demócrata por imprimir
un giro a la draconiana política
migratoria impuesta por donald trump en
la frontera mexicana entre ilusión e
incertidumbre
siento siguen a la espera de poder
volver a ingresar a la unión americana
para continuar allá con su trámite de
solicitud de asilo
nunca se sabe a ciencia cierta la
realidad pero pues estamos con aquella
sensación que de un momento a otro nos
dicen que vamos para adentro y es una
alegría enorme porque vamos a reunirlos
todos nuevamente con nuestras familias
que es algo que ansiamos muchísimo la
hondureña nel y maribel cabrera fue
finalmente atendida en tijuana
desde el año pasado tenía su cita para
la audiencia programada para esta semana
de verdad de que el nuevo presidente ha
dado orden de que se abran las fuertes y
posee este medida de mi corte existe muy
emocionado el nuevo gobierno sin embargo
avanza en este esfuerzo con prudencia
buscando disuadir la llegada de nuevos
migrantes ha anunciado que quien entre
sin un caso pendiente será
inmediatamente expulsado del país
después de varios días de esas primeras
entradas a eeuu miles de migrantes
esperan su turno para cruzar sin embargo
la incertidumbre y desinformación se han
hecho evidentes en las zonas fronterizas
para saber cuál es la situación actual
en tijuana contactamos previamente a la
periodista anabel ya guzmán quien nos
reportó sobre lo que está pasando en la
región con los solicitantes de asilo
nuevamente vuelvo a hacer un espacio
concurrido por la población migrante
estamos precisamente quiere chaparral es
la puerta de entrada hacia los eeuu en
la garita peatonal y bueno como pueden
ver pues hay establecimiento cierto el
campamento podremos decirle de alguna
manera de estas personas que están
intentando tuviera asilo a la unión
americana sin embargo bueno es
importante recordar que no todos podrán
hacerlo en este lugar se han llegado a
concentrar de 100 a 200 migrantes cuando
en realidad se sabe yo solamente podrán
estar cruzando 25 por día sin embargo
pues como les decía hay mucha
desinformación no se sabe quién si podrá
cruzar quien no y bueno por ello las
autoridades han encontrado que cerca del
50 por ciento de los migrantes de estas
personas que están buscando mejorar sus
condiciones de vida son de origen
mexicano el otro 50 son de naciones como
haití honduras el salvador
bien guatemala y bueno pues precisamente
en estos días habrá un evento para
proporcionarles información y asesoría y
decirles tiene cinco bienes estar en
esta comisión de pedir el asilo hacia el
vecino país en los estados unidos de
norteamérica un evento donde se
disfrutará información en temas de salud
además de asesoría médica y sobre todo
el llamado a que no permanezcan aquí
ante la pandemia del bovino 19
a ella le consultamos además sobre cómo
ha sido el proceso para entrar a eeuu y
si existe prioridad para la recepción de
los peticionarios de refugio y bueno
parte del protocolo parte del cómo se se
decide quién es y cuál en cruzar a los
estados unidos de norteamérica el vecino
país de méxico desde luego y quienes no
es importante recordar que para ello
bueno los migrantes deben de haber
pertenecido o de haberse inscrito vaya a
este programa denominado como mpp que es
el llamado protocolo de protección al
migrante que es un trámite que de alguna
manera pues ya habían ellos iniciado
deben de comprobar estar en una
situación de riesgo sobre todo estamos
hablando de muchas familias donde hay
menores de edad y que podemos verlo
insisto en este campamento improvisado
deben de comprobar los migrantes también
haber vivido una situación de violencia
en sus países y de estar en un verdadero
riesgo y sobre todo bueno haberse
registrado ese es un dato muy importante
ante la acnur que es un órgano
perteneciente a
naciones unidas- para ver si son o no
candidatos pueden internarse a los eeuu
no todos estos migrantes que pertenecen
aquí en el chaparral bueno podrán en
algún momento internarse hacia la unión
americana ya que deben de vivir como les
comentábamos estos requisitos
importantes y sobre todo no tener óbice
19 con una prueba que se les hace en los
albergues una vez que ellos están a la
espera de ver si son candidatos o no
para cruzar a la unión americana
mientras avanza a cuentagotas la
recepción de los migrantes el gobierno
de joe biden recuerda que está
comprometido con una reforma migratoria
integral a largo plazo una tarea
pendiente hace años los anuncios a favor
de los migrantes del nuevo gobierno
contrastan con la posible reapertura de
un polémico centro de detención para
menores sin documentos al sur de miami
hasta que inmigrantes de france 24 los
invitamos a comentar en nuestras redes
sociales con el hashtag migrantes efe 24
si ganando más información en france 24
y france 24 puntocom
[Música]